the way we are delivering our mission
right now has to change
we need to act now to reassure the
markets of our fiscal discipline
I have therefore decided to keep the
increase in corporation tax that was
planned by the previous government
this will raise 18 billion pounds per
year
it will act as a down payment on our
full medium-term fiscal plan which will
be accompanied by a forecast from the
Independent obr
hello and welcome to the special edition
of spectator TV I'm Cindy Yu The
Spectators broadcast editor and I'm
joined by Fraser Nelson and James so
James we've just seen Liz truss's press
conference delayed by half an hour to 2
30 and said did it do the task of
reassuring the party the markets for
voters I think it was surprisingly brief
and I and the Press Focus On A Moment
Like This
I think as a politician you want your
own words to provide the headline and
because uh I'm not sure that they were
in this instance because she only
answered I think four questions and she
didn't seem to have a clear message and
I think the problem she's got is having
sex her transfer her closest ideological
allowed and having jumped one of the
main pledges of our leadership campaign
it's quite hard for her to to find a
message that resonates so she says that
um uh she wants to deliver on the
promises she made which invites the
inevitable quick question well why then
are you jogging one of your main
campaign budgets which is to cancel the
corporation tax rise
and she talks about you know how she is
and also everyone knows that her and
quality Crossing worked on this budget
together when she was asked that
question why Harry called the son who is
her biographer a longer for spectators
James Hill I thought it was striking
that she didn't really have an answer to
that question you know well you know
this wasn't what what we planned or
anything like that and I think that in
terms of trying to reassure the
conservative orange market she needed to
she needed to do more than she did in
that press conference today and I think
also in these questions in these
situations how the difficult it is how a
painful it is you want to take as many
questions as possible to show you have
an answer to everything and instead she
was off after four questions and off
walking really quite brisky yeah it was
about eight minutes long Fraser what did
you think of the press conference the
eight minutes was about too long for her
because she wasn't able to desperate to
go off yeah but already she's beginning
to run as always of avoiding the
questions of course he quoting that to
resigned then why didn't she is there
any suggestion this was his idea rather
than hers if he was just doing her video
how can she get away asking him to walk
the plank and dude why is he going at
all why was it necessary to so if she
stayed an extra minute or two minutes or
five minutes the questions would have
got even worse for her and as it was
with the private between the backbend
Championship Wednesday she doesn't have
the answers but isn't the answer here to
just be a bit more contrite to recognize
that you can't push through something
this radical without consensus without a
mandate and she could have recognized
that she made a mistake than that she
didn't well she could have recognized
it's a potentially elaborated on that
she'd have to save as a whole agenda now
remember she did a whole she's done a
whole bunch of things that she didn't
promise during relationship campaign
um over a 45p tax that was extra to what
you promised then there was the very
very expensive 10 billion pounds a month
Energy bill subsidy she could have wrote
back on that that wasn't what you
promised she stood she is only there a
story leader because she promised to
stop the corporation tax going up now
she's abandoned that and she fulfind it
very difficult to answer more questions
about that's like why is she still here
if you're now giving us the Rishi sunak
agenda then why don't we dispense with
you and get receipts scenarios so she
this is not a conclusive answer to her
problems this is a half answer which
raises lots more questions and questions
which she isn't able to answer and
that's why she scared it off I think we
also saw but the kind of
I think with the abandonment of a 45p
the kind of revolutionary phase of a
trust Premiership was over I hope you
saw another end of a phase here which
was in our conference speech she talked
about freedom and disruption and things
like you know as positives here she said
what people crave is stability and it's
a subtle shift but I think it's an
important shift um in terms of what she
is trying to offer people but it is a
big shift from what Liz trust has always
stood for you know she was someone who
has always been on uh the more uh tax
cutting
um disruption you should welcome you
know she talks about young people as uh
there's freedom fighting delivery
ordering Uber riding you know that she
was she was she welcomed disruption now
she's saying what she what people want
is stability and that is what she will
try and deliver the problem is that
things don't look particularly stable at
the moment do you think Jeremy Hunter
someone who can change that I mean she
mentioned that Jeremy Hunt was the
character brought into stability
remember the journey has leadership
campaign I think he wanted a cooperation
to export down to 15 people
race that's 15 people he wanted to keep
the Health and Social care right
Insurance increase that his trust has
jumped which is I thought I thought
presentation me and I know I think he's
coming back from abroad but it was
presentation having a mistake not to
have the two of them together because it
would have provided some alternative
Focus other than just on her which I
thought was very difficult for her for
the reasons that the Fraser said in
these circumstances but for is this the
richest United agenda now given that
Jeremy Hunt supported where she's seen
that during the leadership campaign
after he was knocked out well we still
elements of it she might claim to be
trust science I mean there is the
decrease in National Insurance and
keeping military Manifesto I mean that
was one of her lines she was saying we
as Tories need to keep the promises we
made to be voters in the last election
and that is that we will not increase
the personal tax that from now still
stands as Corporation tanks that's going
up that I have to say it was a very thin
line and she might have regarded this as
being half a concession therefore she
keeps having her credibility that's not
the way I see it I'm afraid to say I
think the credibility is now shocked and
I think it's asking quasi quartet him to
walk the plank is a little bit unfair as
I mean I do I do wonder if he's going to
go public and say for example but she
was looking at the name for example in
the 45p evolution on or I'm not saying
anything about spending when he
announced him in announce his Cuts uh
the apartment's actually a treasury and
I think given the role the Tom's got a
played in terms of relations to the bank
of England which obviously means such a
feature of the reaction to the mini
budget there is obviously a particular
issue there I think that yeah I think it
was interesting his resignation letter
is not uh it's not an attack on her but
it makes it quite clear but she's acting
yeah it's her letter to him almost tries
to suggest that he's resigned in the
National interest and she finds him that
was he is quite clear that he was sacked
rather than resigning it's interesting
because Legends actually because I think
to me he read quite clearly as if she
had said to look why don't you offer to
resign and we'll do it
this is outrageous and the world has got
to see what you're doing so that was the
first that was an important potential
signal of tension between them because
if he does go into tell the side of the
story that could be very interesting and
I think the Tory MPS and I spoke to a
lot of them yesterday about this uh I I
suspect my gutter feeling is that
they've looked at their press conference
and think she's got to go but the only
reason that they're not staying so
openly is because they haven't ex worked
out what to do afterwards now the last
time they wanted to get rid of a prime
minister but didn't really think about
what to do afterwards you ended up in
this mess so the Victorious have perhaps
learned from this that is time to think
things through but I would certainly be
surprised if she is still here in Easter
um as I spent quite a shorter time frame
now but because if you take away if
you've got this truss with that one
that's trust agenda yeah if you take
your weight at her her Manifesto was
Wonder of change of radicalism of we
can't go in this direction we've got to
take it we it'll be crazy if she would
say we will I'm sure the quotes will be
um thrown back if you remember the next
few days crazy to increase cooperation
tax at the time there was a develop
country in the world it's not it's not
as if she not just that she said it
would be nice to freeze it she was
saying it would be ridiculous
um economic Madness to increase taxes
which is now exactly what she's doing so
how sustainable opposition did
politically I don't know and what did
you know I think what is difficult is
that as recently as Wednesday she was
arguing against an increase in
corporation tax and I I think she's also
doing the full fat increasing
Corporation time yeah so so it could
have been like one p or two people no
she's going to go
I think I mean the other difficulty
would for worry locked or MPS was when
she said spending will rise less uh more
slowly than planned yeah
there are obviously many ways different
ways that that what that could mean but
if that means cuts to budgets that is
difficult especially given usually is
just pointed transfer we know Jeremy
Hunt as chairman of the house Select
Community has only bought more money for
help now help makes up 40 of by the end
of this month help make up more than 40
of the day-to-day government spending if
health is going to be protected from
these carts and I actually have its
budget increased the pain and the pain
that falls out as well even greater and
also remember but um as Casey pools
writes in the coffee house yeah but
trustee was pointing out for Jeremy Hunt
shares uh Liz Ross's view of increasing
defense spending to three percent of GDP
so if defense spending is going up and
where it is now three percent of GDP by
the end of a decade Health spending is
going to go up that you know that
suggests some really quite painful
reductions in other departments so she's
not out of the woods yet um Fraser
what's going to happen over the next few
days because there are no particular
flash points but our MP is just going to
be plotting in the background well it'll
be interesting to see how her backers
respond to this she does quite good
support from a daily mail I'm a Daily
Telegraph they're very much in favor of
the budget at last a true story budgets
as a daily mail I wonder what we're
going to be seeing so what are they
going to be sticking with the the
candidate we recommended for the job or
are they going to save and now she's
abandoned their agenda then they're
going to abandon her I'm not a great
believer of the the power of newspapers
when it comes to influencing these
things by the way I mean we journalists
will report very seldom do we make the
weather but it was still I think if
she's in a situation now where she's
facing a lot more hostility with hardly
any government fire at all then that
will make this more of a question of how
language you can survive for the markets
by the way were quite chill today they
expected the end they expected to climb
down they had the guilt Market their
rallied them the the foot Seas rallied
and but I don't really think that the
markets were wanting necessarily A climb
down I just think they're always into
balanced budget there were lots of ways
that were virtually persuaded the market
without doing what she's doing I'm not
quite sure how many of them were calling
for cozy cortex head either he's been
he's a sacrificial lamb and he's been
offered up to the gods of the guild
markets but I'm not quite sure if that
was what what they wanted and so the
conservatives are in a pretty bad place
I would say stuck with leadership's
agenda has already collapsed in a matter
of weeks and and I imagine this would
not do wonders for her own popularity
which was anyway
um charting new negative territory
right well James and Fraser thanks very
much and thank you very much for
watching if you want to hear more
political analysis from The Spectator do
check out daily politics podcast
Coffeehouse